don't let people's outside perspectives
change what you do the easiest thing to
do is to not live presently I don't want
to be in the studio every single day all
the time you know we never sat out to be
like yo like we're gonna make this song
about thrift shops and it's gonna be
it's gonna go multi-platinum because I
know that I want to live up to my
fullest potential I want to be the best
human being that I can possibly be I had
always wanted to get sober I could never
get sober did you ever want to just give
up on your dream yes we did poetry
readings and really what that was was
just acapella raps and I don't want to
look back and be like you had it all and
you weren't even present for it he's an
American rapper from Seattle Washington
since 2000 he has independently released
one mixtape three EPS and four albums
his single thrift shop hit number one on
the US Billboard Hot 100 in 2013 he's
McLemore and hear his top ten rules for
success
don't let people's outside perspectives
change what you do change who you are
dictate your happiness dictate your
level of self-worth affect your
self-esteem and as an artist that's
easier said than done the the public's
perception does weigh on you the box
that they put you in does affect you and
I think that it's a constant fight to
remember why you make music who you do
it for why it's important and to follow
your process and to not let anybody's
outside opinion dictate who you are you
know it I think that um the easiest
thing to do is to not live presently
yeah in life we are consistently in the
past in the future anywhere but right
now and I think for myself as a
performer
it is important to slow down and to
remember what I'm doing why I'm here
remember the words that I wrote the
feeling that I have when I wrote them
and deliver that in the same emotion
that I had when I was in that moment
writing the music both Ryan and I
alright at times I want to say envious
but but we look at other people like you
take Kendrick Kendrick is a rapper
Kendrick is in the studio right now I
guarantee it
he's not thinking about you know that
the merge design that we have right now
isn't fitting on it on a tank top the
way that it should it's true and and
that's a it's a blessing in the curse
you know we we both are have we are the
output in terms of anything creative it
it's a music video if it's directing if
it's writing a treatment if it's if it's
you know being a character in the music
video it we are everything same thing
with their merge same thing with just
the ideas that we have full circle in
terms of running a business so that's
taking away time that we could be
working on our specific crass producing
and rapping so I think that it's a
balance we both enjoy business we both
enjoy being holistically creative that's
a fulfilling thing I don't want to be in
the studio every single day all the time
I want to be picking fonts I want to be
you know with Ryan color editing a music
video that's something that we both
enjoy so it's a balance and I think that
we haven't we wear enough hats that we
can kind of bounce around and be
inspired but it comes at a sacrifice you
know we never sat out to be like yo like
we're gonna make this song about thrift
shops and it's gonna be it's gonna go
multi-platinum and it's gonna be on it
like we didn't have in our mind any
songs that would ever work at radio so I
think we went into the same process with
this one and maybe nothing ends up on
the radio mm-hmm that's great good money
that's because we have money no it's
because it's truly because the art is
what matters in in not and not sales and
not the radio we care about the art and
if that's at the compromise of not
tapping back into a pop audience or or
not being in arenas or not being in
theaters or whatever we're gonna make
the art that we want to make as a
songwriter you you strive for that
perfection but the thing that can kill
you with it and that I learned from from
that website that I went to the thing
that can kill you with it is if you let
that perfectionism stop you from
beginning in the first place and so much
of like what what goes into making a
song it takes courage it takes you know
you battling some fear if you have a
good song you got to write another good
song and there's there's expectation and
the pressure for first and foremost
comes from yourself so staring in front
of a blank piece of paper is a
challenging thing and it always has been
it was challenging when I was 16 years
old writing for the first time it was
challenging at 30 years old it's it's
hard and because I know that I want to
live up to my fullest potential I want
to be the best human being that I can
possibly be
and I want to make the best art that I
can but sometimes you have to write just
to write and if that turns into
something great hone it until it's the
best that it can be and then eventually
put the paintbrush down put like the
final coat of lacquer on the canvas and
just walk away and that's perfect and
that's the same love in 2009 when the
the mixtape and and there was a period
where I think around that time you were
kind of like you know is this something
that's gonna work for me or not what is
it that got you through how did you how
did you work through that yeah I it's
tough to say exactly what I think it was
hard work it was it was discipline it
was knowing that if this doesn't work
out then I will have to get a
nine-to-five
and I don't want to do I really don't
gonna do that and it was it was working
with Ryan and putting everything into
the music and you know for I mean
leading up to that point I think that
you have to look at my track record I
had always wanted to get sober I could
never get sober
I wasn't that I couldn't make music
while I was under the influence of drugs
or alcohol finally got sober in 2008 got
out of rehab and was like alright this
is it I've wasted years of my life and
if this is going to work it has to work
now there's no alternative and I met
somebody that had the same dedication is
me that put everything into the music
everything into the craft and didn't go
out and didn't really have many friends
just kidding just kidding huh well you
only hang out with each other no it's
somebody that wasn't gonna you know be
like you know I was up in to that point
I was making musical people that were
constantly putting their priorities into
getting cooler people getting no not at
all yeah getting um getting loaded or
chasing women or whatever and that's
what I did for a long time and it didn't
it led me to being broken and rehab and
move him back into my parents house
which is awesome but I I wanted a career
in in Ryan was somebody that had the
same discipline yeah and and sacrificed
everything did you ever want to just
give up on your dream yes earlier today
it happens all the time
that's kind of part of being an artist I
feel like is being challenged to push
through those moments of like is this
what I'm supposed to do and the people
that succeed and the people that make it
in the music industry I think that never
goes away as something that you kind of
always are fighting and working against
that's the process of being an artist I
just worked my ass off in my road and
Kent's writing checks recording I wasn't
great going into something like that out
crass
I got out of college
outliers by Malcolm
anyway
this book examines right now that what
makes this place as it's not about what
should local deserve by the talented
should water with its about the habits
that she's put into that time and he
says that around if you like a master
whatever it is that you love to do if
you want to develop that craftsman
sexually she'd have to do his work you
had to work a lot
our Z says that if you put in around
10,000 hours it's about one thing that
eventually you master
hip-hop in Seattle in the late 90s was
grunge music it was it was very
different it was a very small scene
there's a couple hundred people versus
you know it's very different now and we
would we didn't have a place to perform
you know there there was no venues
there's no people to fill the venues if
we could book the venues so what we did
was we did poetry readings and really
what that was was his acapella raps but
you know those took place on Mondays and
a lot of people would get together a lot
of people being like 15 20 people and
and spit each other raps that they've
been working on that week and that was a
place that we honed our skills on a
stage and I don't know if anybody out
there is a performer but I hate it's a
lot more challenging to perform in front
of 15 people acapella than it is for
20,000 people it's a lot more intimate
and that got me to a place of
performance where I felt comfortable and
was able to then transition that into
the stage but it was an imperative part
of my process to be grateful be happy
and enjoy this because it's not promised
who knows where we're gonna be in a year
two years three years we're at this
position now and I don't want to look
back and be like you had it all and you
weren't even present for it you weren't
able to enjoy it I want to be here be
now and and be grateful thank you so
much for watching I made this video
because Ana young asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of
macklemore's top 10 rules had the
biggest impact on you which one did you
like the most
leave it in the comments and I'll join
the discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon